we're pleased to have back here on the
show uh a gentleman who i last spoke
with during the summer
and now here we are a week before
thanksgiving in the middle of a college
football season that is fraught with
as we know quite a bit going on in
college basketball
tipping off in a week the commissioner
of the sec
greg thank you back here on the rich
eisen show how are you commissioner
i'm well rich i'm you know taking it
through david day
by day right yeah i know that's that
that's one of those i guess uh
default ways to start a conversation but
it
is it is infused with quite a bit these
days uh
what how much is your day filled up with
covid
19 commissioner yeah pretty much you
know
when you go back to when we we last
spoke from from that point
um into the start of football season i
was remarking to people
everything we did was about covet we
didn't do our normal preseason work like
at my level my staff
took care of that with our campuses to
make it work
and i looked at our deputy commissioner
and said we're not even
talking about like you know what are we
doing with down markers or
you know the replay structure those
things all have to be in place
and it's the same i just left the phone
call with john calipari right beforehand
with bruce pearl we're just talking
about
what's coming next week with the start
of basketball season not to mention
the disruptions we had last week in
football one announced yesterday
a.d call where we're on for almost two
hours i'll bet you
75 percent of that contact content is
driven out of the current environment
so let's start with basketball since you
said you just got off the the uh the
phone with both
calipari and bruce pearl look you know
at least
you and the nfl um in college football
in the nfl are
are going at it um the the first leagues
i guess
in a contact sport going at it outside
of a bubble
uh we saw the nba had a bubble up i have
no i i
i'll be honest how do you play college
basketball in this environment
commissioner how do you do it well you
yeah you take a step back so we're going
to have
slimmed down crowds um it'll be a
different atmosphere
we've learned that from the nfl and i
think alan silzer chief medical officers
officer has said this we've learned as
well it's the eat meet and greet part
it's not the competition
and the practice and the playing of
games it's what what happens
around the games and so we're we've
heightened our level of attention
i think later today we're making an
announcement
on these kinexon devices that were part
of our learning from the nfl
i wear one every day here it's a
proximity tracker
we've used them in scrimmages and
basketball
with officials and players to figure out
how much time are people spending near
each other
you know we'll get into the space
between benches
so we've learned whether it's soccer
we're playing volleyball indoors right
now and doing that in a healthy way
we have to be attentive to what happens
outside of just the game
that will help us actually play the
games so
um i guess front load what your
announcement is
i wear one of those contact tracers too
when i'm on campus at nfl network
um and i know that that is very helpful
when somebody does
test positive to figure out where they
are and where they've been masked up
and whether they're technically known as
a close contact
so on and so forth but how how will that
allow
an uninterrupted college basketball
season in your estimation
well it facilitates it doesn't guarantee
and just like in in basket or excuse me
in football season
and i probably said this back in our
prior conversation there aren't any
guarantees in this environment you're
going to have to be prepared for
disruption
um and we've learned that
real life that that's happening um the
the
elements of what we're doing includes
testing
it includes the tracking devices and
what you learn is
when that red light starts beeping get
away right that's part of the help and
limiting contact tracing and it's
it's illustrative right now if every
healthy player in football in the sec
could actually play and i'm talking
about contact racing we'd be playing
football without disruption
and so the learning experience is you
have to adapt
to the environment in order to
facilitate healthy play
and it's not simply contact tracing it's
not simply
you know fancy electronic devices it's
not simply testing
it is overall attention to going through
a whole different operating approach so
that you limit
your exposure to people who may be
positive outside your mini bubble on
campus and keep in mind rich we're
starting basketball at a time
when our campuses will pretty much empty
out because they're ending residential
learning
primarily for thanksgiving and so we've
got six to seven weeks to support
non-conference and conference
competition through these protocols
um and we think we can do it a healthy
way the challenge will be to actually do
so
greg sankey southeastern commissioner
conference commissioner sec commissioner
right here on the rich eisen show
and again you know you're uh i kind of
um
hit this with you back in june um in a
facetious way but
we're all becoming best we can public
health experts even though
we're not trained to do that so i asked
that
this next question to you in that light
is what are you hearing
uh on the front lines if you will of the
sports world about the vaccines that
we're reading about and how that might
somehow someway change um
the outlook for a college basketball
season to be done
uninterrupted and then uh maybe talking
about the football season as we move
on what are you hearing about that
commissioner yeah so that's where
you and i are both like suffering right
from sudden expertise
on public health and expertise because
yeah
yeah we're we're learning and we're
reading
and we have been in communication with
immunologists
infectious disease specialists
specialist virologists
and i've always heard privately about
the opportunity
once the calendar flips for the vaccine
to exist and to be effective
the issue will be distribution and it's
real efficacy in the public
and so our doctors have said you know
it's going to go to
this is my interpretation to to health
care workers to front line workers first
there's an
orderliness to what's anticipated i
don't think that
impacts basketball season from the
standpoint of a vaccine making sure
everything's well what i've said to our
staff
and to our campus leadership is we're
going to be
operating in this environment through
the basketball season and in many ways
probably through the academic year
and again that's where i want to just
qualify my sudden expertism
that i'm not the uh the public health
official
that determines this we then talk about
next year so i've been asked about
21 football season and uh i'm likely
more optimistic about a return
to i'll put air quotes around normal
right um
you know when we get into our next
academic year then believing
we're going to have a whole different
operating environment emerge in
february or in march or in april we're
going to have to be dealing with these
adjustments and and virus sensitivities
i would anticipate through the academic
year but i'm not the one who actually
knows and determines that it's just my
synthesis of all that i've heard
let's uh move to football then uh greg
sankey sec commissioner here on the rich
eisen show
um as you are aware i'll just frame it
for those who might not that there are
more
cancelled games this week or postponed
games this week for the sec than there
were games that were actually played due
to covet
19. what is the status of your regular
season
and conference game on december 19th as
it currently stands
right now yeah we can i'm sorry we could
still complete all 10 games for all 14
teams
by december 19th we had talked privately
and we've announced publicly that we'd
use
the 19th for rescheduling of games that
don't involve
teams in the championship game we've got
plans to do that we announced one other
disruption yesterday really as an
outcome of contact racing involving
texas a
m to go back a week um this is not
like an outbreak the reality is
there's a set of of um circumstances
opt-outs early in the year contact
tracing there have been positive tests
but that's a relatively small number and
so my
my statement earlier that if every
healthy player was involved in playing
we wouldn't have had any disruption
but that's not our that's not our
environment so we're still focused on
the finish line of december 19th
uh you know there's talk and probably
some articles even today written about
oh do you adjust the college football
playoff
do you change dates you know i'm one who
thinks we need to have a finish line
i've finished 41 marathons in my life
one of those
was mis-measured that last half mile
that was mismeasured way back in that
one
is a long part of a journey and this has
been a marathon for us and
and so i'm focused on the 19th is that
finish line for our conference schedule
understood that you wouldn't want to
move a finish line but as you know the
virus has its own say
is there a deadline by which a fail-safe
point by which those
new year's six as well as the college
football playoffs needs to be adjusted
and are we approaching that well
certainly we're approaching i don't have
in my own league an infinite opportunity
to reschedule
games we we made plans
for disruption and we're we're seeing
that those plans were
well informed but it's not as if you can
just keep rescheduling i do think there
has to be an end i have not
timelined out by when you'd have to
decide an alteration at the end of the
season
i'm literally like week to week right
now um
and so we've you know the emphasis is
we're going through testing today
uh that informs decision making tomorrow
testing thursday decision making on
friday we've got six games scheduled
the ability to play those guide us
forward um
i don't think you're going to just
adjust with a week's limit if you're
going to change
dates and and that's why rich i really
focus on the 19th is our finish line and
we've made adjustments to tiebreaker
policies and championship
qualification policies um that just
acknowledged there may be
disruption we don't play every game and
um in a few minutes i have left with you
i'd like to focus on the college
football playoffs what is your stance as
the commissioner of the sec
on conferences that won't play as many
games as you
um maybe raising their hands and saying
we want somebody with maybe five games
six games
uh big ten in wisconsin leaves to mind
because of covert they've only played
twice they've yet to play a
a team that's ranked what would be your
stance as the sec commissioner about one
of those teams saying they
they should get a one of the four spots
in the college football playoffs
my stance is consistent with the
selection criteria that's existed which
is
um we charge that selection committee
with looking at the full scope of
schedules
and we know back when the big 12 did not
have a championship
game that the reference to every data
point being very meaningful
and a league like ours playing 10
conference games in arguably the most
rigorous
conference schedule of all uh has great
meaning and if teams play
fewer than that that has to be taken in
consideration and if we're
going all the way down to a team you
know having success with half as many
games
the selection committee is going to have
a responsibility to fully evaluate
the total rigor of a 10 game conference
schedule versus those who may be less
and that's an outcome of decision making
and we were attentive to that as we made
medical decisions and start date
decisions and
moving to a conference only schedule
which has facilitated
our ability to play and and others made
those those decisions all of which
haven't been
implications when we come down to the
end of the season
but taking a template that's been used
in the past for right now
uh might not really be operative
commissioner to be
you know to i guess parry with you here
on this front and
and i've been pounding the table here
about expanding the college football
playoffs this year i mean baseball as we
know expanded
its playoffs the nfl has a plan to
expand its playoffs should cancellations
bring that about we saw what the nba and
the nhl did
about its playoffs totally different
because of the year is there
why not expand your playoffs let more
teams in this year and take the pressure
off the committee in that regard
and also maybe give uh more more
football games to everybody
what about that idea well yeah a few
reasons one
is the more you add when we're living it
now
the more potential you have for
disruption
um we also have other postseason
opportunities
that remain important we have
the ability to conduct healthy
competition which we've demonstrated
but the more and more and more you add
on
the more likely you are not to reach
that finish line which i referenced
earlier
um and the there are limits on what the
number
of there are limits on the number of
games in which participants can play so
we have some
some teams that by the time they play a
championship game we'll play
12 total college football games we're
going to add more and more
where we're going to do that when are we
going to do that or all complexities
have guided us back and i think in a
well-informed way
to maintain the 14 playoff that doesn't
mean it's not debatable that doesn't
mean
everyone agrees but i'm of the view that
that gives us the best opportunity to
still name a national champion
even though we know there's going to be
plenty of debate around those decisions
so basically it's going to be four teams
and if you could play it by the date
that you can play it that's it there's
not going to be any
changes to anything else uh just get to
that finish line
the way that you've planned it yeah
that's basically it yeah sure that's
clearly our direction now but as i
acknowledge earlier you can
see debate around those dates that that
will
likely be introduced we've had a prior
conversation about the potential for
expansion
um among the the involved commissioners
and
and jack swarbrick at notre dame's part
of the management committee
and uh agreed that for provided us the
best opportunity to name a national
champion in this environment
all right last question for you have you
had a conversation with nick saban
to mask up and if so how did that go
actually that one went well um and we've
i've had conversations with others that
have not gone so well
um and and uh i view
our head coaches is having the primary
responsibilities
to set the tone on this expectation when
we started
our plans to play there were certain
expectations one of which was masking so
you know gus miles on nick
i'm trying to run through the guys that
have been at the top
we've even had some pretty good
arguments between coaches they've all
been massed up and where we've had
deficiencies
believe me we've noted it i have staff
believe it or not
who never envisioned in their life
monday morning film review
counting the number of times coaches
show up with masks on and i've
i've had conversations like hey the guy
in the green shirt who's signaling plays
i'm going to remove him from the
sideline if he doesn't wear the mask
and then the next week it's the guy in
the yellow shirt so i'm not sure if
they're trying to hide the guy based on
shirt color but we've made the
expectation clear
try to do it you know objectively and
fairly knowing you can have slips but
that's part of the protocol we've
adopted to facilitate
healthy play commissioner really
appreciate our chat
uh again i really uh always enjoy our
conversations
and uh good luck completing these
seasons getting another one started and
let's chat down the road
appreciate it absolutely nothing's easy
in this environment i would appreciate
the conversation yeah me too that's the
sec commissioner greg sankey here on the
rich eisen show tons of information
there including
he's completed 41 marathons which i
would also drop casually in every
conversation if i had that
big flex wow